hashem obtained a random sample of
students and noticed a positive linear
relationship between their ages and
their backpack weights a 95 confidence
interval for the slope of the regression
line was
0.39 plus or minus
0.23
hashim wants to use this interval to
test the null hypothesis that the true
slope of the population regression line
so this is a population parameter right
here here for the slope of the
population regression line is equal to
zero versus the alternative hypothesis
is that the true slope of the population
regression line is not equal to zero at
the alpha is equal to
0.05 level of significance assume that
all conditions for inference have been
met so given the information that we
just have about what hashem is doing
what would be his conclusion would he
reject the null hypothesis which would
suggest the alternative or would he be
unable to reject the null hypothesis
well let's just think about this a
little bit we have a 95 confidence
interval let me write this down so our
percent confidence
confidence
interval
could write it like this or you could
say that it goes from 0.39 minus 0.23 so
that would be 0.16 so it goes from
0.16
until 0.39 plus 0.23 is going to be what
0.62
now what a 95 confidence interval tells
us is that 95 of the time that we take a
sample and we construct a 95 confidence
interval that 95 percent of time we do
this it should overlap with the true
population parameter that we are trying
to estimate
but in this hypothesis test remember we
are assuming that the true population
parameter is equal to zero
and that does not overlap with this
confidence interval
so assuming let me write this down
assuming
null hypothesis is true
we
are in
the less than or equal to five percent
chance of
situations
where
beta
not
overlap
with 95
intervals
and the whole notion of hypothesis
testing is you assume the null
hypothesis you take your sample and then
if you get statistics and if the
probability of getting those statistics
for something even more extreme than
those statistics is less than your
significance level then you reject the
null hypothesis and that's exactly
what's happening here and this null
hypothesis value is nowhere even close
to overlapping it's over 1600s below the
low end of this bound and so because of
that we would
reject the null hypothesis
reject
the null hypothesis
which suggests the alternative
hypothesis and one way to interpret this
alternative hypothesis that beta is not
equal to zero is that there is
there
is a non-z
linear
relationship
between
between ages and backpack weights ages
and
backpack
weights
and we are done